I'm joined by former happy Monday star
Bears who will also be known to many
people now as a look at a no bears and
also in an iron mental Kaena just tell
us first of all why you decided to join
in this demonstration today well first
of all is there to raise awareness about
fracking and these issues what come with
it and also select people know that the
labor govern as the opposition let the
people go pain abstain on the vote for
money sir audio and putting it to the
people every want for I can do not and
what's up in his hair because that our
government sold in droves we've a big
old government and corporate business as
their main policies are not interesting
the welfare of the people I feel like
after stung and they raise the lens
because you've got the the threat of the
infrastructure bill and CCIP
the fuchsias not working soon great for
the people of Britain but what's wrong
with fracking a lot of people believe
that it can solve a lot of the future
energy problems for the UK but it will
lead to cheaper fuel for ordinary people
what's wrong with that well at the end
of the day that day is a slight like was
we the result soon is out there with
green energies and there and what was
the question again is well it's
basically you know if fracking sold
Britain's energy problem yeah yeah
because I tell you why we shouldn't
because of the co2 emissions alone and
things to your it what we said will fail
miserably on co2 emissions and if our
government don't sell us truthfully that
air we're going to face custard perfect
climate change because of their
decisions they're making on the fracking
then the RBC falls to the people and
come out and really sack so long as the
chief about our futures and what in
sales tools and then we really think we
shall be engaged and a part of the
decision-making but thanks very much for
talking to us this morning